نعلمه تبعتي استقبال الرئيس الامريكي
جوبيدن لنظيره الفرنسيه امانويل ماكرون في
البيت الابيض هذه الصور تاتينا للزياره
الثانيه لمكرون الى واشنطن منذ تواليه
رئاسه في فرنسا وهي الزياره الاولى له في
عهد الرئيس
هذه الزياره يتم التعويل عليها كثيرا هناك
اهتمام في الاوصاف الاعلاميه الامريكيه
بهذه الزياره خاصه مع حملته عناوين بعض
الصحف الامريكيه من ان ثم تتوتر كبير في
العلاقه الامريكيه الفرنسيه ولكنها وصفت
هذا التوتر بانه التوتر مكتوم بسبب العديد
من الاجراءات الامريكيه اخرها قانون يتعلق
بدعم
للمنتجات الامريكيه لمواجهه التضخم ما ادى
الى تداعيات سلبيه بالطبع على المنتجات
الاوروبيه وجعل مكرونه في لقائه ما عدد من
اعضاء الكونجرس بالامس يصف القانون
بالعدائي كانت ايضا تصريحات لمكرون قد
وصفت ما تقوم به امريكا من تحديث سعر
الغاز باسعار عاليه هو يمثل ايضا تحديا
كبيرا
للدول الغربيه مع ازمه الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه على اي حال تترقب كل الاوساط
هذا اللقاء وما سيسفر عنه من قضايا
ومناقشات ولكن تصريحات سابقه كما تقول
وسائل الاعلام لماكرون تقول ان هذا اللقاء
سيكون لقاءا صعبا يحمل عناوين تتعلق بما
يبدو من توتر مكتوب
رئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون كان قد
اعتبر ان الولايات المتحده واوروبا ليست
على قدم المساواه بسبب الدعم الامريكي
الذي تنص عليه خطه حول المناخ والتي تعطي
اولويه للمنتجات المصنوعه محليا وهو ما
اشير او اشرنا اليه منذ قليل بقانون سمي
بقانون مواجهه التضخم وقع عليه رئيس
الامريكي بتقديم الدعم كبير للمنتجات
الامريكيه هذا الامر يشغل بال مكروب بشكل
كبير في هذه الزياره